Leonardo DiCaprio superhot superstar
sorta super talent that beards gotta go
leo
nevermind super actor Leonardo DiCaprio
has not yet won an Oscar for a viateur
he lost to Jamie Foxx for Blood Diamond
he lost DeForest Whitacre that were they
have the [ __ ] that is wolf of wallstreet
he lost to Matthew McConaughey Matthew
what the [ __ ] and now for the last
revenant is going to lose to Michael
Fassbender Leo is running out of options
but there is a game I father's game
yesterday it's so funny I just feel so
bad for him but someone made a game it's
just becoming a joke now that he's never
won an Oscar hi I am Leonardo DiCaprio
and I really need to win the Oscar let's
do this okay let's do this so you press
G and H to chase that Oscar come on
Oscar space to jump out away from
paparazzi I'm so close so close to that
Oscar oh god I missed the Golden Gloves
I don't need you golden gloves I just
want the awesome bonus game oh this is
the scene from wolf of wallstreet 500
bonus Matt Damon oh god dammit my demons
innocent Martian ha ha no [ __ ] you Matt
game and that Oscar is mine
[ __ ] you bestest [ __ ] you Golden Globes
out of your Emmys I don't need you I
want yoghurt excellent act harder oh
look at me I can act
oh my god oh this is so good come on not
come on leo
I love you Leo talk about the
environment Leo no I'm oh there there's
the ice globe global warming it's a
thing it's not just made up come on
almost there I can smell it
find the black nut oh my god this is
ridiculous where's the black this I feel
racist Freeman I can't find it damn it
Bryan Cranston
Oh goddamn it Bryan Cranston Lady Gaga
Lady Gaga you can't act I've seen you in
[ __ ] ledge TV show sorry [ __ ] off
Lady Gaga [ __ ] up [ __ ] up Lady Gaga look
no I'm [ __ ] Leo and I'm gonna [ __ ]
you yeah yeah that's right write your
own acceptance speech I think I should
win because I am so important and I yeah
yeah that's right
humble humble speech all right it's
getting really hard it's getting real
[ __ ] hard [ __ ] oh [ __ ] did you see
that [ __ ] ah ah come on why do you
always slip away I understand the
struggle now Leo I understand what you
have to go through oh no no no no okay
and we said it's reset we're fine
god damn it what are you [ __ ]
paparazzi's what do you want from me
pull these shitty Awards I just want the
Oscar this is getting ridiculously hard
fairness yeah
Quileute overdose come on out
doh oh god all these actors Michael
Fassbender Matt Damon
Lady Gaga Lady Gaga oh god we got
firstly run Lady Gaga got seriously you
can't act just stick to your singing
please write your any Texas speech I am
humbled what a family blonde it is
considering the unbelievable talent in
front of me I think the n-terminus lands
themselves yes what oh my god what oh my
god
oh this is ridiculous okay seriously he
keeps going how do i dodge it
I gotta get the arrows seriously I need
I'm trying so [ __ ] hard at this point
oh come on bonus game right him watch an
F a team on up
ah my fingers hurt they heard oh no not
the only [ __ ] celebrities they run so
fast the struggle the struggle I play
motivational game this is easy is it
possible
oh god this one is impossible there no
what where where I'm sorry alright
that's not racist
it's just I'm blind No
did I fail oh [ __ ] we only have one more
chance yeah warning Lady Gaga me through
I don't even see myself that's
impossible
there's no way Leo can 21 16 Golden
Gloves 43 Emmys
11 empty mover wherever I have 20 passes
SAG Awards but zero Oscars that was
Leo's red carpet rampage you got a good
score let's see if you can beat mine
that is hilarious
let me just say that Leo climbed into a
[ __ ] dead horse for the revenant can
someone just please give him an Oscar
already before he pulls any more weird
[ __ ] alright who knows what Leo will do
next I feel like Kate Winslet broke his
heart I ship them ship them harder than
I ship me and Marcia but it's just not
happening just like Lea will never get
an Oscar but you know what Leo is the
[ __ ] Playboy he doesn't need an Oscar
look at this man look at this man does
this man look like he need an Oscar
I don't think so Leo I love you don't
tell Marty thank you for watching this
video leave a like if you enjoyed and
that was it for me check out the game
it's hilarious and as always